vie colonne de feu visible à des
kilomètres à la ronde il est 15 heures
l'incendié déjà impressionnant
sécheresse chaleur et vent un cocktail
détonnant les pompiers ne veulent rien
laisser au hasard et très vite 80
sapeurs sont à pied d'oeuvre
nous sommes actuellement confrontés un
feu qui a parcouru entre 15 et 20
hectares qui menace un massif forestier
de plusieurs centaines d'hectares
actuellement nous avons dix camions
citernes feux de forêt deux camions
citernes ruraux a plus des moyens
d'alimentation qui sont engagées sur le
feu un camion citerne feux de forêt
équipages au plus près l'objectif éviter
la propagation du feu à la forêt
communale voisine
les pompiers vont ainsi lutté pendant
plusieurs heures mais en début de soirée
le feu est pratiquement maîtrisé
au total 40 hectares de broussailles et
de forêt sont partis en fumée
le sinistre rêve démarré en périphérie
de velars sur ouche un village
régulièrement touchée par des incendies
on est une commune effectivement proche
de la voie de chemin de fer on a
toujours des risques d'incendié
involontaire mais également des risques
techniques liées aux voix là pour
l'instant on ne sait absolument pas
quelle est l'origine
du feu ici au centre du village de
velars sur ouche le poste de
commandement a quitté les lieux dans la
nuit après que le feu était circonscrit
et maîtrisée restent sur place une
quinzaine de pompiers qui vont
surveiller les lieux pour éviter les
éventuelles reprises de feu